the way I Define elite is someone who
will not pay any consequence for their
actions that's basically how an elite is
defined in a system which is as corrupt
as ours is and when you're looking at
somebody like Hunter Biden and our next
story which is the fact that IRS
whistleblowers actually came out and not
just one but two of them and allege that
there was political interference and the
hunter Biden investigation talk about
information I didn't need exactly
although this is exactly what I was
saying earlier with the lab hypothesis
right there's just story after story
after story of the conspiracy theorists
being proven right information that we
were already well aware of I appreciate
these guys coming forward I agree that
this stuff has to come out and it's good
that they're talking about it but the
fact is nobody thought this was going to
be impartial or unbiased under the Obama
Administration the IRS was specifically
targeting conservative groups this has
been a biased Organization for a very
long time it didn't start with Hunter
Biden